this is the simplest kind of circular
motion
and it's where you have a constant
angular
speed constant angular speed right now
we're going to need to draw a new
diagram without people on it so draw me
a circle
okay roughly and
we're going to think about this circular
motion okay so
i actually we're going to do some
constructions off of this okay and for
that reason
you need to make your drawing fairly
accurate which is why i got all the
equipment out okay
significantly i want to ask you a couple
of things firstly
this linear velocity right if we're
talking about uniform
circular motion where the angular speed
angular velocity
is constant so we're going around at a
constant
rate okay so we're making laps
consistently we're not speeding i'm not
slowing down
okay a constant here
a constant omega is going to imply
a constant linear velocity because r is
a constant omega constant
whole thing's constant okay so therefore
if these two things are going to
go sort of complex numbers on you right
if these two lines represent
the velocity if they represent vectors
right
it's got a direction that's why i've got
an arrow on there but this length is
important
okay these lengths in fact because it's
constant they should be the same
okay so what however big your circle is
you know on mine one of these something
like
20 centimeters 25. whatever they are i
want them to be the same on your diagram
it doesn't seem like it's going to be
that important but it will be okay
now i don't know if you've noticed i've
been a bit funny with my language
i want to talk about this velocity
okay now we've already established that
the linear speed is constant
but is the linear
velocity constant it's my question
is the linear velocity constant
now don't forget just to refresh your
memory right we've got two different
kinds of quantities
in this in this world that's 2d okay
we've got scalars
and we've got vectors do you remember
what they mean what does it mean for
something to be scalar
it's just a value with a magnitude it's
just the size right so you can add up
scalar numbers together there's you know
like
three and five they're scalars and you
get eight okay
but a vector makes it more complex not
only does it have a magnitude
but as we've been mentioning it has a
direction right so it's
it's a scalar right plus another scalar
namely magnitude and direction so it's
got two values to it
two parts and so you know under complex
numbers we talked about the real part
and the imaginary part right
in this case we've got direction now can
you see as you go around the circle
direction is constantly changing
you see that direction is constantly
changing at every different point let's
name them say
p1 versus p2 okay
the velocity is changing because the
direction is changing the magnitude's
the same
right you've got the magnitude but the
direction
is not the same okay so that means from
this velocity to this velocity there's a
change right there's a change in
velocity
we have a name for that don't we change
in velocity
what's that called that's acceleration
so there's some acceleration in this
picture okay
my question is where is the acceleration
going now let's have a look at this okay
let me just walk you through that just
in case you lost me there's a change in
velocity
right so step one i notice there's a
change in velocity
so step two i then conclude therefore
there must be acceleration
so then my question is where
what direction is it going in and then
i'm going to go toward the language of
forces
i get forces from acceleration okay all
right now here's where the scale of your
diagram is going to be very very
important
okay am i going to have enough space
over there probably not i'm gonna do it
over here
um you've got your scale there you're
gonna need to draw some parallel lines
as well how do you work out acceleration
acceleration is change in velocity right
so for example if i was traveling
at one point let's see let's start from
this side i was starting my journey and
i was traveling at 10 kilometers an hour
right and then by the end of my journey
i'm traveling at 30 kilometers an hour
10 kilometers an hour 30 kilometers now
how much have i accelerated
it's not a complicated question i've
accelerated
20 kilometers per hour right that's the
that's the net
the resultant acceleration okay so the
way you got that is you take the
difference
you just do final speed final velocity
minus initial velocity and that's your
acceleration
does that make sense so obviously if i
was just you know doing the inertia
thing
and going 10 kilometers per hour and 10
kilometers hour
just uniform straight line motion
there's no acceleration there right no
force is acting or at least
no resultant forces okay so therefore
let's take that understanding and bring
it over here
okay velocity velocity
okay that's change in sorry
acceleration that's what i'm trying to
work out is change in velocity
that's dv on dt okay in this case i'm
just picking two particular points in
time
right here's my final velocity and
here's my initial velocity
just like here's my final velocity and
here's my initial velocity
so i'm going to say well this is v2
minus v1
right in this case i got 20 kilometers
per hour in this case we've got zero
kilometers per hour
what am i going to get here
now here's where you've got to be super
super careful
okay i'm going to try as best i can to
represent this on the board okay
i actually want you to draw the vectors
okay
so if you can make your lines parallel
to preserve the direction of
each might look roughly like this accept
it for me okay
final velocity minus initial velocity
okay no that's way too fast
okay that'll have to do right you can do
a much better job with me because you've
got like rulers and stuff you kind of
measure all that but
bigger one vector and it's velocity
minus the other one
okay i might even label there's b1
and there's v2
now one of the things you may remember
from complex numbers is that when you
are subtracting vectors
subtracting vectors is the same as
adding a negative vector in fact that's
the same in just like normal
numbers right like like uh
30 minus 10 that's the same as
30 plus negative 10 right so all i need
to do to work out what this
is is to well i'll do the first vector
the same
so there's v2
and now instead of subtracting this i'm
going to add
now what would it mean for this vector
to be
negative it means the um the line's the
same
right it's still going to look like this
but because negative it's going in the
opposite direction
right that's that's the negative v1
if you like okay now the reason why this
is useful to us is because when you add
vectors
you just do one and then you do the
other right that's all you have to do to
add vectors together
so that's why i've got this space over
here
okay let's put these together
right something like this
so there are my two vectors put together
which means that the
the net result is this
that's what the um that's what the
change in velocity is when you put the
vectors together and that distance
and the direction are crucial they're
based on these distances in these
directions
okay now let's take that vector and
let's put it into the picture
okay because it's an average of these
two right i'm going to join these up and
get the midpoint looks like this
okay now if you've done it well you take
the midpoint between those two positions
and you have a look at what direction
that's going in it should be heading
right back toward the center at least if
you've drawn it
accurately okay and we have a um we have
a word for this
where it's toward the center and our
fancy
long syllable word for this is it's
centripetal right aiming toward
the center that's where we're going
now i don't know how you feel about that
argument um
i i think it's quite kind of nice like
it's visual right but you know
us we're mathematicians so we want
something a little more rigorous than
this okay
so here's what it looks like visually
but we're gonna need to do it
algebraically as well